"Friends" premiered on NBC nearly 30 years
ago, running for 10 seasons.
In that time, quite a few guest stars, actors
with recurring roles, and one main cast member have died.
Here's the full list.
"Friends" fans were shocked on October 28,
2023, when news broke that Matthew Perry had
died at the age of 54.
The cause has yet to be determined, but as
of the making of this video, he died in an
apparent drowning in his hot tub at his Los
Angeles home.
He was best known for his role as Chandler
Bing, the quick-witted and sarcastic member
of the "Friends" core cast.
When in doubt, Chandler could always be counted
on to deliver a clever quip.
"Could I interest you in a sarcastic comment?"
Over the course of the show, Chandler experienced
some of the best character development out
of all six of the friends.
In the beginning, he was the embodiment of
a noncommittal man-child and corporate hanger-on.
By the time he began his relationship with
Monica at the end of Season 4 and into Season
5, he showed signs of maturity and responsibility.
The two marry in Season 7, Episode 23, "The
One With Monica And Chandler's Wedding," and
welcome a pair of twins in the series finale,
"The Last One."
Perry continued his career in television with
prominent roles in Aaron Sorkin's "Studio
60 on the Sunset Strip" and his own revival
of "The Odd Couple."
He also published his bestselling memoir "Friends,
Lovers, and the Big Terrible Thing," in which
he detailed years of addiction issues.
If "Friends" had a seventh friend, or a character
most familiar to even casual viewers beyond
the main six, it was Gunther, the manager
of the gang's coffee shop hangout.
He was often seen flitting around in the background
at Central Perk, waiting on customers and
pulling espresso shots while rocking a tie,
a loud shirt, and tightly-cropped bleached-blond hair.
On the occasion that Gunther spoke in one
of his more than 150 appearances, it was to
quietly and forlornly express his unrequited
love for former coworker Rachel, or to deliver
a blistering barb against her on-again, off-again
boyfriend Ross.
"When's your birthday?"
"May 5th, why?"
"I'm just making a list of people's birthdays."
"Oh, mine's December--"
"Yeah, whatever."
In real life, to help pay the bills between
gigs in addition to his continuing role as
Gunther, actor James Michael Tyler worked
at a Hollywood coffee shop called The Bourgeois Pig.
He told BuzzFeed in 2014,
"I was one of their first baristas — I think
I started there in 1990 or so."
He appeared on the long-awaited, long-delayed
"Friends" reunion special in 2021, but via
Zoom because of health concerns.
Tyler told "Today" that he'd been diagnosed
with advanced prostate cancer in 2018, and
the disease had spread to his bones.
In October 2021, the 59-year-old actor died.
Jennifer Aniston, who played Rachel, wrote
in an Instagram post.
"'Friends' would not have been the same without
you.
Thank you for the laughter you brought to
the show and to all of our lives.
You will be so missed."
Rachel's overbearing father Dr. Leonard Green
may only appear in four "Friends" episodes,
but he casts a huge shadow over the show,
especially Rachel's character.
Dr. Green was extremely well-to-do in his
career but quite hands-off with his children,
and as a result his three daughters have become
spoiled brats who have no idea how the world
works at all.
When we finally meet gruff Dr. Green in season
2's "The One With the Two Parties," so much
about Rachel's upbringing and current neuroses
becomes clear.
We also have some moments of empathy for Rachel,
who is desperately trying to break out of
the old entitled patterns that no longer serve
her as a wannabe self-sufficient career woman.
While Dr. Green was a character we loved to
hate, we all could agree with him on one thing:
Ross is a jerk and Rachel could do better.
Actor Ron Leibman had a long and distinguished
career across movies, television, and the
stage that included a Tony Award for his work
in "Angels in America."
Leibman passed away in December of 2019 of
pneumonia complications at the age of 82.
Mr. Treeger was the gruff, no-nonsense superintendent
of the New York City apartment building in
which Monica, Rachel, Chandler, and Joey resided
on "Friends," and he factored into the plots
of five episodes between 1995 and 2001.
Probably the most memorable occasion came
in the 1997 installment "The One with the Ballroom Dancing."
After catching Rachel stuffing the trash chute
and making her cry, Mr. Treeger decides to
evict her and Monica from the building, leading
Joey to stick up for his friends and agreeing
to be the super's ballroom dance practice
partner at a superintendents' ball.
Portraying Mr. Treeger was the prolific and
highly recognizable character actor Mike Hagerty,
known for his mustache, his Chicago accent,
and his tendency to play working class characters.
Before "Friends," he played a cable TV station
employee in "Wayne's World" and the best friend
in "Overboard."
After "Friends," he appeared in "Brooklyn
Nine-Nine," "Shameless," and, in 2022, he
was part of the main cast of HBO's "Somebody
Somewhere."
The star of that show, Bridget Everett, announced
on Instagram that Hagerty had died on May
5, 2022, writing,
"A beloved character actor, his love of his
hometown of Chicago and his family were the
cornerstones of his life."
According to TMZ, Hagerty suffered a negative
reaction to an antibiotic used to treat a
leg infection, and he fell into a coma.
The actor was 67 years old.
Before Gunther, for a brief moment in "Friends"
history, there was Terry, the surly coffee
shop owner whose tongue was as sharp as his
black coffee.
While only on screen for two episodes, Terry
offered one of the most cruel descriptions
of Phoebe's music.
It's so dreadfully mean it somehow comes all
the way back around to funny:
"She makes me want to put my finger through
my eye into my brain and swirl it around."
It's also courtesy of Terry that we have one
of the show's most memorable cameos, as Chrissie
Hynde from the Pretenders plays an open mic
set at the café.
Eventually, Phoebe even teaches her the chorus
of her infamous ditty "Smelly Cat."
While actor Max Wright might be better known
for his turn as Mr. Tanner on "ALF," his mark
on "Friends" as Terry is indelible.
Wright passed away at the age of 75 in June
2019 after a long battle with cancer.
A key part of Monica's character arc finds
her chasing her lifelong dream of being a
chef, and on her difficult road down that
path she writes a review of Allesandro's Italian
restaurant for the Chelsea Reporter.
The review absolutely eviscerates the establishment
to such a degree that its owner, Allesandro,
actually comes to Monica's apartment to chew
her out.
While there, Monica learns that the reason
the food was so bad was because Allesandro
doesn't actually know how to cook.
Also, he's not even Italian — he's Lebanese.
After tasting Monica's food, a begrudging
Allesandro invites Monica to be his new head
chef, which turns into another huge conflict
as the old head chef was literally related
to everyone else on staff, so their anger
turns to her.
She concocts shenanigans with Joey to get
her new staff to take her seriously.
Actor Taylor Negron, who memorably brought
Allesandro to life, was diagnosed with liver
cancer in 2008 and succumbed to the illness
in January 2015 at the age of 57.
Ross Gellar's relationships are so dysfunctional
he's on a first name basis with his divorce attorney, Russell.
Russell is constantly disturbed by Ross' compulsive
behavior, but he also recognizes a cash cow
when he sees one, calling Ross one of his
favorite clients thanks to all the business.
Ross got divorced not once, but twice in a
year, first from Emily Waltham after saying
Rachel's name at the altar, and then later
from Rachel after a blackout drunk drive-through
Elvis wedding in Vegas.
Russell is the one to give Rachel the unfortunate
news that Ross didn't actually file the annulment
papers since he didn't want to be divorced
three times.
"Ross!
Are you crazy?
I'm still your wife?"
The moment has big consequences for the entire
gang, not just Rachel and Ross.
Played by Ron Glass — who was better known
for his roles on "Barney Miller" and "Firefly"
— Russell was a rare voice of reason on
"Friends."
Glass passed away in November 2016 of undisclosed
causes at the age of 71.
"Friends" didn't often go into dream territory,
rarely exploring alternate avenues for the
characters or offering fresh perspectives
on the past and future.
But thankfully, fans do have the two-part
"The One That Could Have Been," which dives
into an alternate universe in which Rachel
married Barry, Monica never lost all that
weight, Joey stayed on at "Days of Our Lives,"
Chandler is an aspiring comedian, Ross and
Carol remain unhappily married, and in the
biggest twist of all, Phoebe is an investment
banker who chain smokes rather than a floopy
vegetarian masseuse with a unique fashion sense.
It's in Phoebe's portion of the story that
Paul Gleason, perhaps best known as Vice Principal
Vernon from "The Breakfast Club," appears
as her boss, Jack.
He's concerned after Phoebe loses millions
of dollars on a bad deal and has a heart attack.
Gleason passed away in May 2006 at the age
of 67 after struggling with mesothelioma and
lung cancer complications caused by asbestos
exposure.
One of the other narrative tricks that kept
things lively on "Friends" was the overwhelming
number of celebrity cameos, with A-listers
often playing love interests for the gang.
One of the rare non-romantic cameos comes
courtesy of Robin Williams and Billy Crystal
as Thomas and Tim in "The One With the Ultimate
Fighting Champion."
Thomas and Tim make their way onto the gang's
couch in Central Perk on a particularly busy
morning as a hysterical Thomas tries to figure
out who might be having an affair with his wife.
As it turns out, the culprit is Tim himself,
which unfolds in dialogue that was improvised
by Williams and Crystal on set, according
to Screen Rant.
"You are no longer my friend!
We are finished!"
The gang is in awe, and rightfully so, watching
these two comedic masters at work.
Heartbreakingly, Robin Williams died by suicide
on August 11, 2014, after a long struggle
with a number of physical and mental health
issues.
He was 63.
Ross Gellar famously had a pet monkey during
the first season of "Friends."
Marcel is a capuchin who starts off sweet,
but quickly grows more and more aggressive
as he ages, leading to an uncomfortable adulthood
in which he cannot stop humping everything
around him, including Rachel's childhood stuffed
animals.
As his friends get more and more annoyed with
Marcel's disruptions, Ross decides to let
the Bronx Zoo adopt him.
But when he goes to visit, he finds out from
shifty zoo administrator Dean Lipson that
Marcel has died.
Or has he?
The intrigue builds when a janitor tells Ross
that Marcel has been shipped out to California
to become an actor in Hollywood, and the zoo
wants to keep the information under wraps.
When Ross finds out that Marcel will be starring
in "Outbreak 2" filming locally, he's able
to say goodbye to his old friend with his
favorite song, "In the Jungle."
Comedy icon Fred Willard might only have been
on screen briefly in "Friends" as Lipson,
but he brought his characteristic snark to
the role in a way that played perfectly with
Ross' natural suspicion.
Willard passed away in May 2020 of a sudden
heart attack at the age of 86, never having
retired from acting.
In Season 4's "The One with Joey's Dirty Day,"
Joey lands another acting gig.
This time it's a high-profile one, in a movie
starring the legendary Charlton Heston.
Before he reports to the set, Joey takes Chandler
on a fishing trip, and upon returning, falls
asleep while memorizing his lines.
He doesn't get to take a shower before going
to work and smells terrible, so he sneaks
into the only dressing room equipped with
a shower — Heston's.
The seasoned professional discovers Joey,
writes off his misbehavior to nerves, and
warns him not to cross him again.
"Put some pants on, kid, so I can kick your
butt."
An icon of epic biblical films in the 1950s,
Heston starred as Moses in "The Ten Commandments"
and the title character in "Ben-Hur," which
won him an Academy Award.
In the '60s and '70s, he shifted to headlining
big-budget dystopian sci-fi movies, including
"The Omega Man," "Planet of the Apes," and
"Soylent Green."
Heston's family told CNN that the actor died
at home in Beverly Hills on April 5, 2008,
at his home, not long after entering the latter
stages of Alzheimer's disease.
Heston was 84.
Joey often talked about his large Italian
family and his grandmothers in particular.
Season 5's "The One Where Ross Can't Flirt"
introduces one of them, Nonnie.
Joey invites her over to see him on an episode
of "Law and Order."
However, his scenes ended up getting cut,
so he scrambles to film a fake "Law and Order"
episode to trick his Nonnie, who reportedly
doesn't know any English other than the name
"Sam Waterston" and enough to eavesdrop on
an embarrassing conversation involving Ross.
French actress Lilyan Chauvin played Nonnie.
In the years before that appearance, she regularly
featured in "The Young and the Restless,"
"Days of Our Lives," and "Falcon Crest."
She also hosted and produced the business
cable TV talk show, "Hollywood Structured."
After "Friends," Chauvin guest-starred on
"Ugly Betty," "Frasier," and "Malcolm in the Middle."
According to Chauvin's Los Angeles Times obituary,
the actor died in June 2008, four decades
after a breast cancer diagnosis, due to congestive
heart disease.
She was 82.
The same person played two very different
roles in back-to-back seasons of "Friends."
In the Season 6 episode, "The One with Rachel's
Sister," Alexis Arquette plays a customer
at Central Perk.
And then in Season 7's "The One with Chandler's
Dad," Arquette returns as a server at the
Las Vegas drag club where Chandler's transgender
parent performs.
Both episodes make clear reference to family,
and Alexis was part of the prominent acting
Arquette famliy, along with siblings Patricia,
Rosanna, and David.
David was a fellow "Friends" guest, and once
husband of Courteney Cox.
A transwoman, Alexis documented her transition
in "Alexis Arquette: She's My Brother."
Arquette was best known for small but important
parts in two major '90s movies: the reluctant
criminal who unloads a gun at John Travolta
and Samuel L. Jackson's hitmen in "Pulp Fiction,"
and the Boy George-obsessed keyboardist in
the wedding band in "The Wedding Singer."
Arquette died in September 2016 at age 47
due to a bacterial infection and cardiac event
complicated by HIV.
Stan Kirsch was only on one episode of "Friends,"
but it was a very memorable one that would
possibly cause some controversy if it aired
today.
In "The One With the Ick Factor," Monica goes
to a college party and pretends to be 22 instead
of her actual age of 26.
She meets a cute guy named Ethan who says
he's a senior, and Monica agrees to go out
with him even under her false pretenses, thinking
he's in college.
After the two sleep together, Monica finds
out that Ethan is really a senior in high
school, and only 17 to boot, making this not
just an "ick factor," but an actual crime
in some places.
"My lie didn't make one of us a felon in 48
states!"
Kirsch, better known for his long run on the
"Highlander" television series, played Ethan.
He died by suicide in January of 2020 at the
age of 51.
Iris is Monica's aunt who shows up in the
Season 1 episode, "The One with All the Poker."
She is a bit abrasive and rough around the
edges, which is probably why Monica seeks
her assistance in helping her and her friends
learn how to play poker.
Aunt Iris is apparently an old card sharp
who's been playing poker since early childhood.
She agrees to help, but is rude, impatient,
and claims to have hit Tony Randall with a
car — but that was just a lesson in bluffing.
Beverly Garland played the sketchy aunt, one
of nearly 200 roles in a nearly 60-year career.
"Really?"
"No!
That's bluffing!
Lesson number one!"
She started off in low-budget movies like
"It Conquered the World" and "Swamp Women,"
then portrayed Barbara Harper Douglas in "My
Three Sons," one of the dozens of sitcom parts.
In December 2008, the Los Angeles Times reported
that Garland died at her home in the Hollywood
Hills following a long period of illness.
Garland was 82.
Phoebe's adoptive grandmother Frances only
appears in one "Friends" episode, but it's
a very significant one for the most eccentric
friend of the bunch.
Pheebs didn't actually know that she and her
sister had been adopted at all.
All the photographs of her "father" around
Frances' house were actually the placeholder
images that came with the picture frames,
explaining why Phoebe insists for the rest
of the series that her grandmother is in hell.
Thankfully, though, before Frances' death,
she guides Phoebe to her actual father, Frank Buffay.
Phoebe also finds out about her brother, Frank
Jr., which sets up many new character arcs
for the most eccentric of the Friends and
her even stranger family, like the time when
she carries her brother and his much older
wife's triplets.
Frances was played by Audra Lindley, iconic
for her role as Mrs. Roper on "Three's Company."
She died in October of 1997 after a long struggle
with leukemia, meaning she never had a chance
to see how her small appearance on the show
would in fact change pop culture history.
Sadly, too many "Friends" guest stars have
passed away to discuss them all in full in this video.
The others include:
Gary Collins, who played himself
Conchata Ferrell, who played a judge in Season
Joel Beeson, who played Todd the Hombre Man
Mary Pat Gleason, who played Nurse Sizemore
Shelley Berman, who played Mr. Kaplan
Peter Dennis, who played Sherman Whitfield
Kellie Waymire, who played Colleen
Gretchen Wyler, who played Mrs. Burkart
Phil Leeds, who played Mr. Adelman
Alaina Reed Hall, who played The Admissions
Woman
Richard Roat, who played Burt
Danny Dayton, who played Buddy Doyle
Paxton Whitehead, who played Mr. Waltham